how's the drama around the draft there
Mike oh you know this is the time where
you never know what to believe and what
not to believe who's lying who's not
lying who's putting out a smokescreen
it's such a competitive process because
it's chess checkers and chicken and
everybody wants the guy they want and
they'll say whatever they have to do to
try to get the guy they want all right
uh we we know who's going one and two or
do we all we do I mean look anything can
happen theoretically that would maybe
render one of the top two quarterbacks
unavailable to play football I want to
jinx anybody but at least the fourth of
July isn't coming up or anything like
that but we know one and two okay so we
know it's go off and we know it's winds
correct yeah okay is there more drama at
three with San Diego or four with Dallas
that's a good question and that's my way
of buying time because they don't really
know the answer I'd say there's
different drama with both of them with
the Chargers they're essentially in
position where they have the first pick
in the draft because they're not going
to take golf or wens although they took
Rivers when they had drew brees under
contract but they're not expected and
weren't expected to take one of those
guys so they can go Laremy Tunsil the
left tackle they can go a defensive
player maybe Jalen Ramsey or DeForest
Buckner but with the Cowboys that's when
it gets very intriguing because if they
put his eq Elliott's name on a card at
number four you take a running back at
number four you better be sure this guy
is going to be Jim Brown or Barry
Sanders or Adrian Peterson or Emmitt
Smith or anybody who would be the exact
opposite of Trent Richardson the guy who
was taken at number three back in 2012
because you can get running backs
anywhere and everywhere so you better be
convinced that this guy's going to be an
all-time great if you put his name down
and I'd love to be in the draft room for
the discussion between Steven Jones and
Jerry Jones about what they're going to
do because Jerry Jones wants a win now
he wants a guy who makes the biggest
impact now and like Steven Jones is more
inclined to think longer term who's
going to help us three four five years
out yeah I find the Cowboys more
intriguing than San Diego like I mean we
have a basic idea of where San Diego is
going to go you know maybe four guys
that you include but if you take if you
take elliott at four
Dallas changes the rest of the draft you
know in some ways the Bears love him the
Dolphins love him maybe the Giants would
take Ezekiel Elliott so I think there
are a lot of teams saying if he said if
they take bosa what's that mean for the
rest of the first round so I find the
Cowboys far more intriguing than San
Diego well with the charges in position
where they could still trade that pic
now recently tanta let's go the GM said
that the calls have diminished but if
there's somebody who decides in the next
36 hours that there's a guy they must
have at essentially the top of the draft
once you take out golfing once the
Chargers could in theory move down
talking to Mike Florio ProFootballTalk
on the NBC sports network we've been
talking about the Raiders and Las Vegas
now we know the mark davis's kick the
tires on San Antonio and Los Angeles and
now it's Vegas but but Vegas somehow
feels real is it a mirage and no pun
intended well III look if it's going to
be great leverage to get Oakland to
finally do something then it has to feel
real and it was just a few years ago Dan
that the possibility of Las Vegas
hosting an NFL preseason game came up
and the NFL shut it down immediately not
a consideration won't be playing games
in Las Vegas and now all of a sudden Las
Vegas is acceptable now there will be
owners and I was told this back at the
league meetings in March there will be
owners who are steadfastly opposed to
ever playing a game in Vegas having a
team in Vegas etc but if 24 total say
it's fine by us they can put a team
anywhere they want they can do anything
they want they already play games in
london multiple times a year there's
betting parlors everywhere in london
their attitude is hey When in Rome we do
what the local custom is okay fine so
you go to Vegas and there's gambling but
you've got procedures in place to ensure
it doesn't affect the integrity of the
games and you get a state if I talk
about paying for the stadium sixty-six
cents on the dollar via tax is imposed
on tourists at a time when taxpayer
dollars are not available for the most
part to build these stadiums some point
you gotta go you go where the free money
is and is going to be free money in
Vegas because once you get the NFL there
the others
words will follow suit I think you know
once the NFL is your battering ram
you're going to have hockey there but
this is different if the NFL goes you
know baseball who is somebody else going
to use that dome Stadium you know you're
not going to have it for just eight
games so that you know UNLV can use it
but I i get the feeling if you're
building an all-purpose dome you're
trying to attract a final for a variety
of things is super bowl there so I don't
know it just feels like there's a little
more there because you follow the money
and there's certainly money there well
and when the money isn't there elsewhere
the taxpayer money isn't there elsewhere
that the shift has to happen and you
know there's just been this quiet sense
that the NFL starting to accept the idea
that gambling is part of the reality of
the NFL part of the reason why so many
people watch it and I think they're
trying to find a way to have it both
ways where they can stay above the fray
they can claim that the integrity of the
games aren't being undermined in any way
but they can at least rub elbows
especially if it's going to result in
stadiums being largely paid for by
someone other than the NFL or its teams
we've been talking about Sam Bradford
and the Eagles and I get the feeling
that after the draft is when Sam
Bradford if he's going to get traded
would get traded teams are going to find
out where they stand with a
quarterbacking situation after the draft
but your thoughts on how this plays out
in Philadelphia why I don't know why Sam
Bradford is surprised that he's not the
guy in Philadelphia his contract streams
out that he's not the guy at the
two-year contract and there's only one
way to become the guy for any team you
play well you earn the spot and you
continue to play well and you keep the
spot any franchise quarterback out there
the minute they're not playing like a
franchise quarterback they're not going
to be the franchise quarterback any
longer so you got to earn it and you got
to keep it and if he wants a divorce my
suggestion is how about an annulment
cough up the 11 million dollars the
Eagles gave you as the starting point
and he's only gotten half of that money
pay back to 5.5 and let's work out a
trade because I think that 11 million
dollars ends up being an impediment to
working out a trade the Eagles just
going to eat it is another team going to
pay the Eagles the 11 million dollars I
there's no one else out there that views
Sam Bradford the way he wants to be
viewed by the Eagles
so until Bradford recognizes the reality
of situation I don't see how this gets
resolved but it's a two-year deal which
should tell you if you're at that age
you want to try to cash in one more time
and get a five or six year deal I i'm
assuming unless he thought all play
really well I've got more leverage to
either get a long-term contract at age
what 30 or you know I can go someplace
else but doesn't a two-year deal kind of
scream you're not our future yeah yeah I
mean the best approach for Sam Bradford
is just go play well go play well did
drew brees complain when the charge was
drafted philip rivers or did he go play
well and he ends up landing a contract
with a wrecked shoulder for 60 million
dollars which was a huge contract at the
time in New Orleans does Tom Brady wine
when the Patriots use a second-round
pick on his potential replacement or
does he just redouble his efforts to
make it impossible for the Patriots to
ever take him off the field you play
well you keep playing well and you take
anything that the team does that would
be perceived as a threat against your
job as motivation to do your job even
better that's what Bradford should be
doing I think the way he's handling it
makes him less attractive to another
team out there that would be inclined to
consider giving him a chance because if
he's complaining like that in Philly
it's just a matter of time before he's
complaining about something in his new
city Cardale Jones is he moving up like
hey I know I unlike you I can't trust
anybody that I you know anything that I
read but it feels like Cardale Jones the
Ohio State quarterback there's a little
more inertia here I don't know help me
out all it takes is one team just to
like a guy earlier than anyone else
likes him and to see something there I
am that was great the national
championship game he was great in the
win over Alabama and something happened
last year that caused him to fall out of
favor and Urban Meyer didn't do the guy
any favors recently when he made some
fairly passive aggressive remarks about
Cardale Jones work ethic and his
intelligence and his willingness to
apply himself and avoid distractions and
it's not exactly the kind of thing you
want to hear from the guys college coach
two weeks before the draft but I think
somebody's going to see something and
it's going to be it the commodity of
quarterback is so important in the NFL
that if you can get a guy who can come
in and be a difference-maker your
roll the dice and the lower you get in
the draft the easier it is to justify
rolling the dice thanks bud I know
you're busy thanks for joining us damn
right that's Mike Florio the Dan Patrick
show weekday mornings on audience